what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
as promised this week's video on how to
kill superheroes is juggernaut now as we
always do with our videos on how to kill
superheroes we're going to provide kind
of a brief rundown on what the character
is about and what they're capable of but
something that I want to point out here
is that in this video we are not going
to be invoking a stay juggernaut because
then it would be like well I mean I
don't know like it would be it would be
stupid to try to figure out a way to
kill that version of juggernaut and
we're certainly not going to be invoking
juggernaut from the Trion storyline so
uncanny x-men number 369 because I think
it was ah because then at that point we
would have to invoke like mad Jim
Jasper's or Matthew Molloy or Franklin
Richards or like Galactus or something
like that and even then there's no
guarantee that that that version of
juggernaut could be killed so we're
going to be focusing on normal
juggernaut that is to say the one that
we usually think of whenever we think of
juggernaut I imagine why people don't
know about triage or not he was a
hundred feet tall he could rip
dimensions in half he could destroy the
very fabric of reality it was stupid how
powerful that version of juggernaut it
was absolutely nuts anyway
the juggernaut came into being when the
stepbrother of Charles Xavier Cain Marko
found the gem of the demonic entity CID
Iraq in a hidden temple in Korea now the
gym transforms came in to sit erect
avatar the juggernaut an immortal
embodiment of suresh power
now as the avatar of cid iraq girona
possesses an impressive array of powers
first of all the gym imbued in Kaine
superhuman strength and in fact the
juggernaut is so strong that his punches
have registered as an eight on the
Richter scale which is typically used to
measure the strength of earthquakes he's
even been able to project his strength
beyond his own reach in the form of
thunderclaps
that can produce shockwaves powerful
enough to knock some of the strongest
opponents in the Marvel Universe on
their bus to add to that the juggernaut
strength is not limited to physical
objects as he's been able to shatter
magical constructs created by dr.
strange seemingly without any difficulty
and he's even been able to stand
toe-to-toe with some of the heaviest
hitters in the model universe including
Thor and Hyperion one of the many
versions of Marvel Superman now in
addition to super-strength
nice difficulty to kill is bolstered by
his durability that's so extreme that
he's effectively invulnerable to
physical damage when his physical body
is attacked in addition to punches from
Thor and Hyperion's the juggernaut his
weathered blows from the Incredible Hulk
and its world breaker Hawk form one of
the strongest version of the Hulk has
ever appeared in comics and was not
harmed when hit by Thor's God blast
furthermore juggernaut has demonstrated
that he does not need air to survive
which was evidenced when he was buried
under millions of tons of rock clay and
stone without suffocating now Jenner not
is not only inherently durable but is
able to generate an extremely powerful
protective force field that can make him
completely invulnerable to any attack on
his physical body juggernaut force field
has survived blows from Thor's hammer
Mjolnir and been able to push back
against Jean Grey's telekinesis although
it's worth noting that this was very
early on in Jean Grey's training and
juggernauts history now in the unlikely
event that juggernaut does take damage
he's able to heal almost instantaneously
which is evidenced when the juggernauts
eye is stabbed out by shatter star and
grows back immediately now what really
sets the juggernaut apart from most
other powerhouses in Marvel Comics is
that once he starts to move he's
impossible to stop hence the reason why
he's often referred to as the
unstoppable juggernaut when moving at
full speed juggernauts able to run
through planets and is knocked over the
celestial being known as the stranger
now there have been a couple instances
when he was actually stopped although it
shouldn't have been possible as we noted
earlier juggernaut was not harmed by the
God blast of four however the blast was
long enough to stop his momentum which
juggernaut indicated had never been done
before
later juggernaut had stopped by the Hulk
who had been beefed up with tech from
the Celestials after becoming
apocalypses Forsman of war it's worth
noting however that without that
technology Hulk in his normal form and
even his world work or Hulk form would
not be able to stop the juggernaut
something that we saw during World War
Hulk when banner simply diverged the
Hulk movement as opposed to stopping him
in his entirety and so the question that
we have to ask is this how do you stop
someone and then kill that person when
their power is literally to be
unstoppable on top of that if you do
stop them how do you kill someone who's
impervious to physical damage well for a
long time
there
a relatively simple answer to this
question although achieving it would
still have been extremely difficult
throughout the vast majority of its
history juggernaut has been vulnerable
to telepathic or psychic attacks so in
theory a powerful telepath could
penetrate cane Marcos mind and convinced
him to simply give up the gem of
cyttorak
thus losing his powers and making him
mortal again of course this is easier
said than done as juggernaut wears a
metal helmet to shield him from such
attacks now since juggernaut is a
character with a long history he has
been written by several different
writers and how hard it is to remove
this helmet has varied from writer to
writer
that being said has been removed by
several characters over the years
including extremely strong characters
like Hulk Thor or Nimrod two other
seemingly weaker characters like siren
beast and Angel so despite how strong
and invulnerable juggernaut was there's
always been a clear weakness that could
be exploited to defeat him the problem
is that all of that change in 2015 and
the amazing x-men story written by Chris
Yost
and a story called the once and future
juggernaut the Crimson gem of cyttorak
appears in an ancient temple and calls
out to various candidates including Ken
Marcou to become the avatar sit erect
simce marco lost the power of the
juggernaut during the events of fear
itself
initially came seeks out the gym in the
hopes of destroying it but after the gym
claims a super villain living monolith
as the new avatar and he subsequently
begins destroying the island colossus
convinced it iraq that the living
monolith will ultimately fail him and
that in order for iraq's avatar to
truly be successful he must be given
enough power to kill cid iraq himself
while colossus was hoping to Sid Iraq
would choose him as the avatar and he
would be able to kill Sid Iraq Sid Iraq
actually chooses to give the power of
the juggernaut to Cain Margo once again
this time making him almost as powerful
as he was during the eighth day
storyline now after receiving the power
of the juggernaut once again Cain takes
off his helmet and Rachel gray attempts
to read his mind
but is unable to do so at this point can
explains that every weakness he'd ever
previously had no longer affects him now
clearly this complicates matters quite a
bit if we can't exploit his weakness to
telepathic attacks juggernaut becomes
pretty much impossible to kill what's
even more puzzling is that due to the
fact that juggernaut has not appeared in
comics that much if at all since this
time in Marvel's timeline we have no
idea of gauging at what level his powers
currently are
all we know is that after receiving the
powers this time around Jagger not was
able to withstand an all-out assault
from Colossus
without being hurt even a little bit but
if Kane is telling the truth we also
know that juggernaut is more powerful
than he's ever been which given his past
feat is quite problematic for us so as I
see it that leaves us with only one
option to defeat and kill the juggernaut
we have to convince the demons in Iraq
to withdraw his power from commune Marko
now this has happened before in 2011
during the marble crossover event fear
itself in this event Cain Marko picks up
a hammer that was sent to earth by the
evil brother of Odin Kol borsch son also
known as the serpent now after picking
up the hammer came becomes an entity
known as Kurth the breaker of stone and
operates under serpents control to wreak
devastation on the x-men now in order to
prevent this from happening
kitty pryde colossus and magic travelled
to the home dimension of sit iraq and
helen mccain is now under the control of
the serpent and responds sit iraq takes
the juggernauts powers from Cain Marko
and transfers them to Colossus there is
a story where Colossus becomes
juggernaut and I think I did it once and
I am going to remaster that I'm going to
do it again so ah what we can learn from
this is that sin Iraq will basically act
out of self-preservation if you feel
threatened what we have to do then is
somehow convince Sid Iraq that is in his
best interest to withdraw his powers
from Cain Marko once again now how we do
that I have no idea but we have to come
up with something maybe find a
replacement avatar that fit Iraq would
find more worthy to step up and take
Kane's place this could work although we
would need someone that could resist the
demons influence after receiving the
power of the juggernaut and so short of
depowering Cain I don't see any way that
he can be killed other than like a
reality war for who just wills him out
of existence which is a trump card the
Marvel always has available since
there's always a ton of reality war pers
just kind of floating around the
landscape but that's kind of how I see
things going down now a question for you
guys in the Rob Cork and our scenario
where we have to grab somebody else to
undertake the mantle of juggernaut in
place of Cain Marko who do you think
that person should be if you could give
one person in Marvel Comics the crimson
gem of cyttorak
to become the new juggernaut who do you
choose I'm actually really curious to
see what direction you guys going I
really want to know who you guys choose
like in my mind truth be told if I had
to take a person I would pick apocalypse
I would
apocalypse juggernaut it would be insane
like it'd be nuts could you imagine that
like it was like shape-shifting all like
all kinds of crazy stuff it'd be it'd be
awesome to see apocalypse where the
power of juggernaut or maybe the
Incredible Hulk I feel like The
Incredible Hulk would be too easy but
like a Hulk juggernaut would be insane
but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end and
yeah leave a comment down below let me
know who else you guys think we should
kill I'm thinking about doing Solomon
Grundy next that's kind of my that's
kind of what I'm thinking about the
problem is Solomon Grundy's like already
dead so how do you kill a guy who's
already dead ah it creates kind of a
weird situation but it'd be fun to try
to figure it out my riders gonna hate me
but without being said guys are going to
bring this video to an end if you're new
here to come with explain be sure to hit
the sub button to become part of the
rock or if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you on let it please
[Music]
you